I thought that it was gonna just blow  over I don't know I didn't think he was  gonna turn twist okay  we can look at this picture we see we  know that he's a psychopath but it's not  the way the rest of the world is going  to see it there's a video you're a true  talent the skinny one right here is this  supposed to be me  marmalade hmm what happened to him he  sneaked out in the mail van yes I  tracked him as far as Paddington Station  but then he disappeared I'm sorry it's  just that creature needs a great deal to  me boy is he endangered hmm the thing  that haunts me are all the guys that I  couldn't save now I'm willing and able  to be there but I'm not I'm here I quit  he can walk down any Hall in this  hospital we got plenty of soldiers need  saving mm-hmm  I want to take a walk